>> WELCOME BACK TO "THE BIG
SATURDAY SHOW."
IT'S TIME NOW FOR BIG SATURDAY
FLOPS, OUR PICKS FOR THE BIGGEST
FAILS OF THE WEEK.
I'LL GO FIRST.
ALL RIGHT, SO YOU HAD THAT
SCANDAL WITH THE FISHING
CHEATING, BUT NOW WE HAVE
ANOTHER SCANDAL THAT AMERICA'S
GOING TO BE TOTALLY WATCHING.
THE PROFESSIONAL CORNHOLE WORLD
HAS BEEN ROCKED BY A GAGGATE --
BAGKUWAIT CHEATING SCANDAL. --
BAGGATE CHEATING SCANDAL.
YOU'RE A SPORTS GUY, THEY GOT IN
TROUBLE FOR USING BEAN BAGS THAT
WERE ILLEGAL BECAUSE THEY WERE
TOO SMALL, AND THERE'S $15,000
ON THE LINE.
>> IS THIS A SPORT OR IS THIS A
DRINKING GAME?
>> IT'S BOTH.
>> YEAH.
A LITTLE COLUMN A, COLUMN B.
>> WHY DO YOU HAVE TO HAVE IT
ONE OR THE OTHER?
[LAUGHTER]
>> WELL --
>> IF YOU CAN'T DRINK WHILE
DOING IT, IT'S NOT A SPORT.
>> WHAT ABOUT THE CHEATING?
AND IT'S THE SAD, I CON CHEM IT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> -- CONDEMN IT.
>> WAIT, CAN I SEE SOMETHING
ABOUT IT?
I'VE BEEN FOLLOWING -- RIGHT.
APPARENTLY, ONE OF THE TEAMS
COMPLAINED BECAUSE THEY THOUGHT
THEIR BAGS WERE TOO SMALL, AND
THE OTHER TEAM WAS LIKE, ALL
RIGHT, I WANT YOUR BAGS TO BE
CHECKED TOO, AND THEIR BAGS WERE
NOT REGULATION EAST.
>> ALL THE BAGS WERE OFF.
THEY HAVE TO BE A SPECIFIC SIZE
AND WEIGHT S. AND I'M NOT A
PROFESSIONAL CORNHOLE PLAYER,
BUT I ALSO THINK WE MOW
ENOUGH --
>> I AM NOT ATHLETIC, WHICH IS
GOING TO COME AS A SURPRISE TO
NO ONE.
[LAUGHTER]
I'M PRETTY GOOD AT CORNHOLE, SO
I WAS DEEPLY INTERESTED --
>> GREAT GAME.
GUY.
>> VOTER DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN
CRYING SUPPRESSION AHEAD OF THE
MIDTERMS, WATCH.
>> THE EXTREME MAGA ELEMENT OF
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY SUPPRESSED
THE RIGHT OF VOTERS AND SUBVERT
THE ELECTORAL SYSTEM ITSELF.
>> VOTER SUPPRESSION IS ALIVE
AND WELL.
WE'RE WATCHING IT HAPPEN RIGHT
NOW IN DOHERTY COUNTY.
>> DON'T LET ANYBODY TELL YOU IT
DOES.
HERE IS WHY I KNOW IT DOES,
THERE'S SOME FOLKS WORKING
REALLY HARD TO MAKE SURE YOU
DON'T USE IT.
>> WE HEARD JIM CROW, PRESIDENT
BIDEN CALLED IT WORSE THAN JIM
CROW, THE NEW GEORGIA LAW.
WELL, LOOK AT THAT NUMBER ON
YOUR SCREEN RIGHT NOW, WELL PAST
2.2 THE MILLION BALLOTS ALREADY
CAST EARLY IN THE STATE OF
GEORGIA AFTER THE LAW WAS
IMPLEMENTED.
THAT IS A SMASH RECORD IN THE
MIDTERM CYCLE.
THE LYING ABOUT JIM CROW AND THE
SUPPRESSION HAS BEEN EXPLODED
BEFORE OUR EYES, AND I THINK
THAT THAT'S SOMEWHAT SATISFYING.
>> REPUBLICANS SAVE DEMOCRACY.
CHARLIE, WHAT HAVE YOU GOT?
>> THE ULTIMATE FLOP THIS WEEK
IS JOHN FETTERMAN, HIS BACKDROP
OF AMERICAN FLAGS BLEW AWAY.
>> OH, MAN.
>> I WOULD SAY THIS GUY, THESE
GUYS ARE SNAKE BIT EXCEPT FOR
IT'S ALL OF THEIR PRO-CLIMB --
PRO-CRIME POLICIES --
>> THAT'S AN AM AMATEUR CAMPAIGN
THAT FORGOT TO BRING THE
SANDBAGS.
FLAGS CAN'T HIT THE GROUND.
>> A CRITIC WOULD SAY THOSE
FLAGS ARE RUNNING AWAY FROM HIM.
I AM NOT SAYING THAT --
>> AMERICA IS RUNNING AWAY.
>> MY BIG SATURDAY FLOP, LOOKS
GOOD ON THE OUTSIDE, ROTTEN ON
THE INSIDE, IT'S DAYLIGHT SAVING
TIME, AND EVEN THOUGH EVERYONE
WILL GAIN AN HOUR OF VEEP, I
THINK IT SHOULD BE ELIMINATED,
AND THE SENATE PASSED A BILL TO
MAKE DAYLIGHT SAVING TIME
PERMANENT.
THE BILL IS CALLED THE SUNSHINE
PROTECTION ACT --
[LAUGHTER]
WHICH I THINK IS POSITIVELY
ADORABLE.
>> YEAH.
>> CONGRESS' APPROVAL RATING IS
AT, LIKE, 18, 20%, IF THEY WANT
TO BUMP THAT UP --
>> I'M FROM ARIZONA, WE'VE NEVER
DONE THIS --
>> YEAH, THAT'S RIGHT.
>> TAKE A LEAD PROSECUTE GRAND
CANYON STATE -- FROM THE GRAND
CANYON STATE, WE LOVE THE SUN
THERE.
>> DON'T DO DAYLIGHT SAVINGS.
>> I THINK WE'RE THE ONLY ONES.
BUT FACT CHECK ME, I'M NOT SURE.
>> ALSO, A LOT OF MY FRIENDS
HAVE BABIES, IT'S NOT GOOD FOR
THE MOM.
[LAUGHTER]
IT'S VERY TOUGH.
THIS HOUR ABSOLUTELY FLEW BY.
IT WAS GREAT TO BE WITH ALL OF
YOU.
THREE MORE DAYS?
>> TWO DAYS, T